nick's with us in jacksonville florida
hi nick how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'm
very well sure good how can we help
well uh let me give you a little info i
am 35
i'm divorced uh i just finished my
associate's degree
no alimony no kids um but i do have
33 000 uh credit card debt 32 000 in
student loans
i just started my first semester of my
bachelor's degree i'm very excited about
that
and my goal is to finish my education
without taking any more student loans
that's good and so right now i make
about 4 600 a month net and my
outgoing is 3 800 and i've
cut my expenses where i can i'm paying
500 a month on my credit cards
since i'm still in school i don't have
to pay student loans yet but i'm paying
about 700 a month out of pocket for
tuition
and my car payment is 425 a month
now i own 9 400 on my vehicle
and it has a trade-in value of about 7
400. but i got an offer
to trade it into the dealership at an
unspecified above value
i was looking at similar vehicles and it
looks like i could lease
a similar vehicle for 200 a month i've
got two years left on this six year loan
for my car
should i trade it in and lease a vehicle
for two years so that i can
put an extra two hundred dollars towards
my debt not stick with what you got
yep it's it's a real tough binge but
it's a short
it's a short pitch and your worst case
scenario is you got to pick up some
extra work while you're in school which
is going to be very strenuous
but if you could kick your income up a
thousand dollars a month it changes all
this equation
yeah yeah and nick you're doing a great
job i love how you broke down your
hammers yeah you know you know where you
are
that's a big deal that's huge man so i
agree with dave stick right there
get a little bit more income you're
gonna be all right bro in two years yeah
this is tight and you know where you are
and you know what you got to do
and so you're looking at options but now
i i here's the thing
the right financial decision almost
always is
harder in the short term and better in
the long term
the wrong one is always better in the
short term and worse in the long term
and most people do the second one that's
why they're broke so and that's where
this cat this falls in that category